fans of Britain's royal family around
the world are celebrating yes we are the
newest addition to the family the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex better known as
Harry and Megan have a 7-pound 303 ounce
baby boy empty as tyub is outside the
grounds of Windsor Castle that's west of
London where the new parents live empty
eyes good morning to you good morning
well it's just over 24 hours since the
birth of the Royal baby and we're
getting some unconfirmed reports about
where he was born
we're hearing that he may have been born
at a hospital in London and not at home
at Frogmore cottage as was widely
expected still waiting for the palace to
confirm that one but we can say with a
lot of certainty is that there was no
one happier about the birth than dad
Harry on Monday new dad Prince Harry was
beaming as he announced the birth of his
son I'm so incredibly proud of my wife
and as every father and parent we'd ever
say you know you your baby is absolutely
amazing but this little thing is sharing
in the delight Laurie Sparhawk from
Houston royal reporter Roy Anika says
this royal baby was always going to be
unlike any other we now have the first
British American Prince born into the
royal family that's a landmark moment I
suppose it shows how it reflects how
international and diverse and we are in
society baby Sussex is seventh in line
to the throne but he won't be called his
royal highness
after titles were limited around a
century ago not that that matters to
Andrea Thompson who traveled to Windsor
from London with her two sons
she says the newest member of the royal
family is a reflection of Britain today
well certainly when I was growing up
as a mixed-race woman I felt very
distant from the royal family seeing
Megan marrying into that family now it
marks a time where the royal family more
now than ever reflecting what real
Britain is her sons Alexander and James
are also pretty excited about the new
arrival did you know that Harry and
Megan had a baby it's a boy too just
like you guys are you excited yeah well
we just heard from little James and
Alexander whose names interestingly
enough are among the top favorites by
bookmakers for the newest royal we could
learn the name of Harry and Megan's son
when they released his first images and
those images could come as early as
tomorrow
gale oh boy we can't wait to see it I'm
so sad we missed it because as you know
we were just there over the weekend not
that we would have seen the baby at all
but just to be there I wanted to get the
tests the tests the temperature of the
town I really wanted to be there when
that happened MTX tie up lucky you you
get to see what everybody is thinking
and saying thank you so much